- Disgraced celebrity
lawyer Michael Avenatti
sentenced to two and a half years in jail
for a scheme related to suing Nike.
If you don't recall,
Michael Avenatti represented
a putative whistleblower
who said that Nike
was paying high school
and college students
to sign Nike endorsement deals,
which was, of course, illegal.
But the problem for
Avenatti is that not only
was he trying to get money for his client,
he was also trying to
get money for himself.
He tried to extort Nike
for millions of dollars
so that he could run an
internal investigation
of Nike's practices and he'd
get paid as a consultant.
Pro tip, as a lawyer you
are not allowed to do that.
So a jury convicted Avenatti
on three counts related to extortion,
interstate communications
related to extortion,
and wire fraud.
And he now has been sentenced
to two and a half years in
jail, and, on top of that,
he faces other charges in California
where he could face
even more time in jail.
So we're definitely going to
see Michael Avenatti in court!